مشاهدينا لا تزالوا داروا رعايه الطفل
اليتيم في السودان والتي تعرف بالمايغوما
تتصدر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وذلك بعد
وقوع قذيفه بمحيط دار الايتام قبل نحو
يومين الا ان ماساه الدهر رعايه الطفل
اليتيم تعود لاسباب تحديدا منذ اندلاع
الصراع بين الجيش وقوات دعم السريع في
العاصمه السودانيه حيث قضى العشرات من
الاطفال ورضع بسبب سوء التغذيه بعد
استحاله وصول غالبيه الموظفين بحسب ما اكد
عدد منهم حيث اكدت المدير الطبيه لدارما
ان مال يقل عن 50 طفلا من بينهم عشرون
رضيعا على الاقل توفوا في الاسابيع سته
الماضيه مشيره الى ان ثلاثه عشر طفلا على
الاقل توفوا يوم الجمعه الماضيه فقط بدوره
اكد مسؤول كبير في دار الايتام هذه
الارقام وقال جراح تطوع للعمل
بالجراح والتطوع للعمل بالدار خلال الحرب
ان عشرات الايتام توفوا وقال
كلاهما قال ان الوفيات كانت في الغالب
لحديث الولاده واخذ تقل اعمارهم عن عام
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات